Thank You Amit yeah so as a mitzvah is
going to be a talk about attacks on
multilinear maps and defenses and also
what we can do even if these attacks are
around so i want to say up front this is
going to be a fairly technical talk in
in spite of who goes a request that we
we be as conceptual as possible there's
going to be a lot of technical details
and i hope that by the end of it you
know many people understand a lot of the
details about how these attacks work and
maybe we'll tell you about how we can
modify the the multilinear maps to to
defend against them but so since it's
going to be technical if there's any
questions at any point you know please
interrupt me i want to make sure that
people are are following ok so let's get
started so I just want to refresh amid
mentioned in his talk what are multi
linear maps but let me just refresh your
memory or for those who weren't here so
if you recall a bilinear map is defined
on a pair of groups g1 and g2 and it has
the property that if you have a
generator in g1 raised to the power a
and a generator in g1 raised to the
power B and you apply the multi linear
map it moves you into the into the
second group g2 but multiplies the
exponents okay so you know if you
multiply these two elements in g1 the
exponents would add and the multi linear
map allows you to compute products of
exponents by moving into the second
group multilinear maps are just a
generalization of this 2k wave functions
so now we you know you can think of it
as having k groups and and the the map
would operate on on inputs of length K
instead of length 2 so multiply our maps
have tons of cryptographic applications
a sort of canonical easy one to see is a
k plus 1 way diffie-hellman key exchange
so with bi linear maps you can do three
way diffie-hellman key exchange and so
on and the current candidate
constructions we have actually realize a
noisy version of this so we're
some additional randomness in the maps
and these things are usually called
graded encoding schemes and I'm going to
talk about these now and explain what
they are it's a slightly different way
of presenting on which i think is more
useful for for how these are used and
and also how they're attacked okay so
integrated encoding scheme we have some
plain text elements check and call em
and these are going to be encoded with
some encoding e and each encoding is
going to be at some level I ok and so in
notation I'm going to say that E is an
encoding of em at level I with these
square brackets with the IG noting the
level ok so what can you do with these
in coatings let's say we have three in
coatings a-133 where e 1 and E 2 are at
the same level I and III is it some
other level J ok so what can you do with
these in coatings well you can add them
if they're at the same level so i can
add a 1 and E 2 and this produces an
encoding of m1 plus m2 at the same level
I and I can also multiply across
different levels so if i can multiply e1
and e3 and this would give me an
encoding of the product m1 times m3 and
now at level I plus J weary one was at
level I and III was at level J ok and
then the final thing I can do is 0 test
so given an encoding I can check if it's
equal to 0 if it's an encoding of 0 but
there's a crucial caveat which I can
only perform the 0 test if I'm at the
top level ok so there's some maximum
level k and the 0 test will only give me
a meaningful answer if the encoding is
at the top level K and specifically it
will tell me whether or not it's an
encoding of 0 ok so I think it's useful
to think about these greater than coding
schemes in contrast to fully homomorphic
encryption ok so but in both graded
encoding schemes and fully homomorphic
encryption you do these arithmetic
operations on encoded values themselves
ok so I don't need to like decrypt to do
the arithmetic I can just do it on the
encoded
I use themselves but there is there's
some some crucial differences so in a
graded encoding scheme when I decrypt so
think of decrypt as the zero test I only
decrypt to get 0 or 1 so in particular I
don't learn the actual value of the
encoding unless it's 0 I just learned if
it's zero or not in contrast in fhe when
you decrypt something you get the actual
value that was encoded okay and another
key difference is that for graded and
coding schemes you can only decrypt at
the end of the computation in some sense
when you've reached a maximum level and
in contrast in fhe you can always
decrypt there's no notion of levels in
this way okay and the reason why I'm
sort of pointing out these differences
is because I think this illustrates why
graded encoding schemes are kind of
naturally suited to do program
obfuscation right so what you want to do
is give out some encoded inputs allow
people to do computation on them and
then at the end sort of decrypt and see
the result and let's say it's a boolean
function so the result is 0 or 1 so with
fhe you can do these things but you can
also do more which we don't want
froggies gation right you can also
decrypt the intermediate values which
we'd what you don't want yeah sure
that's true that's another good point so
you can think of so for the 0 test
there's going to be a sort of key it's
it's there's going to be a parameter
that lets you decrypt it's not like if I
have an encoding of zero I can just look
at it and see there is a key that is
going to be used to sort of get the
answer it's sort of a yeah you can think
of it as a like defective fhe key so it
instead of letting you decrypt it just
lets you see if it was 0 or not it's
public yeah it's public ok so let me
briefly now go through the history of
graded encoding schemes candidates from
the last about two and a half years so
the first breakthrough one of these was
due to guard gentry and halevi at the
end of 2012 this is a candidate based on
ideal lattices ok and
pretty quickly after the same author is
notice that there was something called a
zero rising attack on this candidate
which essentially means if I have some
low-level encodings of zero in some
specific form i can actually attack the
scheming and break the security in some
sense i'm going to be informal here on
the slide okay in in 2013 there was
another candidate due to coron the point
and Taguchi and this is a candidate over
the integers which uses Chinese
remainder theorem representation okay
last year there was another candidate
ggh but this is a different ggh this is
gorbunov gentry and halevi and this is
yet another candidate that has a
different form the previous two and in
particular kind of has a more lwe like
form than the previous ones do okay late
last year there was a there were some
attacks on on the CLT candidate and and
particular Cheon Han Lee Ryu and steli
gave a zero izing attack on on CL t so
like the zero rising attack on ggh this
attack required on relied on low level
in coatings of zero and then this we
this was quickly extended in joint work
with with coron gentry halevi Lapointe
maji rico vasai hi Tabuchi so this
extended the attack of gianna doll to
different settings and in particular to
settings where we don't assume there's
any low level encodings of zero so this
is this is really like a conceptual
contrast of the previous attacks up
until this point all known attacks on em
maps required low level in coatings of
zero and now for the first time we can
we can start to see that there's there's
a tax even when when these are not
present okay so earlier this year there
was a new version of CLT by the same
authors which modified the original one
to sort of resist
the 0 rising attacks and then even more
recently than that there was a new
attack on ggh 13 and this is not really
a zero izing attack but this attacks the
sort of key exchange protocol using
using those and coatings so this list
actually keeps going on I ran out of
room on the slide but but you can see
that this is like very very active area
lots of back and forth is Amit said and
the reason for this what you know why
everybody is so interested in these
things is because they have amazing
number of applications so you know
obfuscation is sort of the the gold
standard application but there's many
other applications like witness
encryption functional encryption and
many other things i'm not going to get
into the the motivation about or
applications of these on maps but they
are numerous and instead i just want to
talk about how the m maps work and how
we attack them and how we can hope to
prevent these attacks okay so and in
particular today the talk is going to be
about the the CLT family of em maps okay
so we're going to talk about the the CLT
I'm map itself the 0 rising attacks from
from last year and then and then maybe
is going to talk about the new version
of CLT which which seeks to defend
against these attacks okay and
particular I'm not going to cover many
things such as the original 0 rising
attacks on on ggh aggh 13 I'm not going
to talk about what's known about the
crypt analysis of GG age 14 there's also
an extension of the attacks this is in
our upcoming crypto paper an extension
of the Chiana at all attacks too ggh 13
which which actually doesn't rely on
low-level zeros either I'm not going to
talk about those and these recent
attacks on ggh 13 including this one by
you and Gia and more recent ones I'm not
going to talk about these either so this
is really going to be focused on the CLT
family of em maps
okay so here's the plan for the rest of
the talk first going to give an overview
of the CLT 13 candidate itself and how
it works and then talk about the zero
izing attacks on it and then Mady is
going to talk about the new candidate
CLT 15 and then at the end depending on
if there's time I'm going to say a
little about what we can hope to do even
if these attacks are inherent even if we
can never eliminate zero izing attacks
what can we still hope to do is your
candidate based on idea let us assist
and destroyed or is it only big no good
okay so so the there is an attack on the
GH 13 candidate if you have in coatings
of zero of a certain form oh sorry yes
without a little of zeroes okay that's
true they're sort of your not directly
given low level zero you're given matrix
matrices of ggh encodings in a form
where there there are low-level zeros
but they're not directly given up so
yeah I don't want to emphasize this too
much because this is not an attack
directly on the under ggh scheme and it
doesn't break anything any application
that we that we know of but but I still
there that it you know there's an
interesting observation that that this
can extend even to the city not to my
knowledge may be no i don't not not yet
hopefully not that ever
okay foot pedal seems the latest attack
shafi the attack on the mpk protocol
that also uses low level according to
zero so when the guard did you do dishes
there hey there just are one little
example of an attack without Lorraine
yeah are you saying that falls the
scheme that it was discussed would still
would still work with either ggh or CLT
13 or CLT 15 in India okay so one thing
is if the scheme requires composite
order maps then you cannot use ugh their
team because this is prime order but
other than that yes the answer is yes so
in particular all of the obfuscation
schemes are not broken by these attacks
and the reason is that the encoding is
given out there do not have the form
that is necessary to apply the attacks
yeah I'll come back to that but yeah I
want to emphasize is like several times
throughout the talk none of the NC 1
obfuscation candidates are broken by any
of these attacks because the encoding do
not have the correct form there's some
some simplified variants of these
schemes which we can break but none of
the ones as they're published are broken
with the tourism schemes of each is
assumption again presented is false true
but because the only use assumption is
not yet fulfilled if you feel yes that's
true yeah but that doesn't mean that the
the schemes themselves abreast okay okay
so let me let me get into the details of
how CL 2 13 works okay so CLT 13 has
some system parameters has two sets of
primes the p primes and the GE primes
and the peas are going to be much bigger
than the g's okay then it has this value
z which is going to be used to sort of
encode the level of the encoding okay
and so the primes and this this level
value z our secret and there's a public
parameter which is a modulus so this is
going to be a
noted x0 and it's the product of all of
the large Prime's the the prm's okay
plain texts in the CLT scheme are
vectors vectors / z to the g1 through Z
to the GN so it's a vector where eat
where the i'th component is some number
modulo GI modulo the small frame so this
is short yeah the plain texts are short
relative to to the modulus in particular
and so the encoding czar going to live
in Z to X 0 so this is modulo the the
modulus x 0 and the encoding czar going
to be done via the Chinese remainder
theorem okay so this is just overview of
what things are going to look like what
would things we're going to be using ok
so how do we encode so let's say we have
some plain text vector and one through
MN and we want to encode at level J ok
so the encoding looks like the following
first we have the the level value so we
have Z raised to the minus J so J is the
level we want to encode at and we're
going to multiply this with the CRT
representation of this vector e1 through
en defined as follows so AI is the
message or the yeah the message vector
the message slot mi plus some randomness
which is divisible by the prime GI Z is
is this is just going to be used to sort
of encode what level you're at and this
is actually going to be the least
important thing and all of the attacks
disease are just going to kind of go
away so you can safely ignore them if if
there's too much notation on the slide
ok so so again we have we have this this
level values e raised to the level we
want to encode at minus j multiplied by
the CRT representation ok and notice
that in each component of the CRT
representation if i take that component
AI
mod the corresponding prime GI so
remember this is a small prime I get
back the the message bit so these these
components encode the message values mod
GI in some sense so am I is super short
and E I is short just something yeah
yeah mi is very short e I is is short
but it's of course larger than I mind
but I'm and the G eyes are very short
and the randomness also is very short so
most things are very short what's not
short is this value is e to the minus J
so this is large so in a particular
encoding will not look like a small a
small value in this in this industry
okay so so this is the kind of invariant
that we want to maintain in these in
coatings and we're going to do
arithmetic on the encoding just mod X 0
so when encoding is an integer mod X 0
and we do arithmetic on them mod X 0
okay and as long as you're following the
rules of the arithmetic I had on the on
the second slide so you only add at the
same level and you and when you multiply
the levels the level numbers add this
invariant will be maintained as long as
the number of operations doesn't get too
large so as long as you do some some
bounded polynomial number of operations
which is you know determined by the
parameters of the scheme this invariant
will be maintained and the encoding will
will still have the the proper form
okay so now let's see how zero test
works ok so for for notation I'm going
to define this value p I star which is
essentially not essentially which is the
product of all the primes except the I
a--the okay so it's a product of the
primes PJ as long as j not equal die
okay so with this notation the 0 test
parameter looks like the following it's
a CRT it's a Chinese remainder theorem
representation of some vector which I
will explain x level value so there's a
couple things to note here so first of
all the level that we're multiplying it
by is K so the 0 test parameter has the
Z to the K which sort of corresponds to
that you should only apply you only be
able to apply the zero test at the top
level it's ok here is the top level okay
and then what are the components of the
of the CRT look like well each one has
this p1 star p I star which is the
product of all the primes except to I
and then it has some randomness h and
the small prime G inverse this I know
this probably looks like a big mess
right now on the next slide you're going
to see how the zero test works and these
things will the reason for these things
will become clear for now I just want to
say that these these P I stars have this
property that if you want to compute the
the CRT representation of a vector where
the i'th slot is divisible by P I star
then the CRT representation is just the
sum of the of the elements mod X 0 okay
so this is this is going to be as fun
this is this essentially is follows from
the Chinese remainder theorem or you can
see it as a component in the proof okay
so to clear things up a little bit let's
see how a 0 test works let's see how a
successful 0
test works okay so let's say I have some
encoding let's call it a at the top
level okay so what this means is that
the encoding a is of the form Z to the
minus K representing the level x CRT
where the i'th the I component of that
CRT is the plain text message plus some
randomness which is divisible by the
prime G ok and then the zero test
parameter has a similar form so it has
this level component Z to the K and it's
a CRT of some stuff that I described on
the last slide ok so to do the zero test
you take your encoding you take your
zero test parameter and you multiply
them and that's it you then you you're
gonna you're going to check if this
value is small or not but the the
operation of doing zero test is just
multiplying these two things ok so
what's going to happen when you multiply
them right these are going to cancel so
you just left with the CRTs and now if a
is an encoding of 0 what that means is
that all of these misr 0 so the M eyes
are gone ok and when you multiply two
CRTs they multiply component wise so if
the MIS are gone then this GI will
cancel with this GI inverse ok so so
that's that's essentially what this says
so if if all of the message slots are 0
you do the zero test by multiplying the
encoding and the zero test parameter and
what you get is just a CRT vector CRT
representation of this so this is the
these this P I star this randomness H
from the zero test parameter and the
randomness are from the encoding ok and
the crucial thing here is that these are
all small ok so H I and our I we're both
chosen to be much small
lower than the prime P I and this is the
product of all the primes except the
eyes and so in particular each one of
these is much smaller than x0 recall
that x0 is the product of all the primes
okay so and again because the CRT
representation has this form where each
each slot is divisible by this this P I
star the CRT is equivalent to just
summing these these these elements okay
and because all of these things are
small the sum is going to be much
smaller than X 0 and this is how you
recognize a a successful 0 test so if
when you multiply the encoding and the
zero test parameter you have something
that's much smaller than X 0 then this
tells you that your encoding was an
encoding of 0 at the top level K and if
not so if if there's some message slot
which is not equal to 0 or the level is
not equal to K things will not simplify
like this and you will have some some
big values that are big relative to X 0
and so you will get a number which is
which is roughly x0 okay so this this
equation right this what happens with a
successful zero test this is essentially
the simplicity of this equation is what
allows the attack the zero rising
attacks to work so in particular I want
to note a couple of things one is that
this equality holds over the integers so
without modular reduction meaning that
if you you take your your encoding and
your zero test parameter you multiply
them and reduce mod X 0 so you have some
value this is equal to this sum and it's
not just equal to it mod X 0 it's
actually equal to it okay and then the
other thing which I'll note here but
this whole this will come back when
we're going through the attacks is that
this sum actually has a kind of simpler
form which is that it's just the sum of
the r is which which came from the
encoding a but then it's these our eyes
are multiplied by some other things that
don't depend at all on the encoding ok
so these are just system parameters
these all these please p I stars in the
hhi are all system parameters so when
you do a successful zero test you wind
up with the sum of something that
depends on the encoding times some stuff
that has nothing to do with the encoding
yeah what'd happen if you use these a
good buy new year what do you mean two
levels okay so I mean two levels would
correspond to two k equal to 22 so
actually i'll tell you what when i go
through the attacks it's going to be
very tight example so it's just going to
be two primes in three levels so maybe
it'll be it'll be more clear okay any
other questions yeah it's not a
composite number but they just would it
to be obviously okay ah yeah I believe
this this should be easily broken i'm
not sure exactly what the the form is
but so the if you have the primes p I
and a particular if there's only one and
you know it you can recover all of the
other system parameters i'm not i'm not
going to go into the details of that but
but knowing the primes is of is a break
on this thing so in particular if you
can factor x 0 you you break the
security of this game
the GI so so the GIS I believe you can
you can recover the GIS with essentially
you if you have enough encodings you can
do g cds to eliminate these things so if
you have enough in coatings of zero and
you know all the primes p I are you
asking if you just know the primes GI
I'm not sure okay yeah maybe says we
don't know if an attack if you just know
the GIS so it's no secret yeah yeah yeah
yes tries what were they doing here what
could this be one right i mean so for
the purposes of this they they can be i
mean they wouldn't affect the
correctness i may be made you can say
something about why you decided the HS I
think my impression is just more
randomness you know is better but but
you're right like not everything on this
slide would go this far enough to see
what they act level 2 k and that would
be bad I mean it's something that's not
too small so that you can't square it
and still no but the GI is would square
them to know so you just you just well
then you need more see you need to
multiply more zeros okay now multiply it
with 10 encoding and the 0 test will get
rid of one of the details i driving okay
any other questions okay so now let's
see how some of the 0 rising attacks
work okay and I'm going to I'm going to
start by presenting the the attack by
Gian at all okay so I'm going to I'm
going to show this as a kind of in a toy
version of this where the number of
crimes is just too and the top level is
three so so there's two slots in each
CRT and you you need to multiply like
three encodings to get to the top level
ok so this attack is going to assume
that you have three sets of encodings
which i'm going to call an a set a be
set and a/c set ok so the a set looks
like this this is just notation so all
these in coatings are at level 1 and
this is just to remind you that an
encoding a is a CRT of some some numbers
multiplied by Z to the minus 1 or / z
okay and then the be set and the cset
are the same this is just just notation
to remind you of what the encoding look
like ok so you'll notice that all these
sets have size 2 but this is because
this is a kind of toy example so in
particular when you when you do the
attack for real the a and the C sets
have size n so you need one encoding in
each of these sets for each prime that
there is but here we just have two
primes so there's just two encodings in
each set ok and then the middle set B
there's always two encoding so
regardless of how many Prime's you have
this middle set is always just going to
have to in coatings and in some sense
you can think of these middle and
coatings as the target of the attack so
what the attack is going to recover are
essentially going to be these CRT values
in here ok so we're going to use the a
and the C sets to recover the sort of
hidden values in these encodings here ok
so you know unsurprisingly we cannot
just take any set of sets of encodings
we need these to have some special
properties and in the Chiana doll attack
what they say what they require is that
the a sets are all in coatings of zero
ok so each each AI is an encoding of
zero and recall that this means that if
a so for example if a one is an encoding
of zero it means that each slot in the
CRT representation is divisible by the
the corresponding G prime right because
they have the form like G times some
randomness plus the encoded value in
that slot so if the encoded values are
all 0 then then each of the CRT values
are divisible by by G by the
corresponding GI ok so it was observed
by us and also by Bonneville and
Zimmerman that in fact this assumption
is not necessary for this attack so we
do not need to assume that the DA is in
code 0 and it's sufficient instead that
the following is true for any way of
choosing 11 encoding from the first set
one from the second and one from the
third for any way of choosing those the
product is zero at the top level ok so
it's it's enough to satisfy that if the
AI is in code 0 but you could imagine
other forms where for example the you
know the AIS might have zeros in the
first slot and the CIS have zeros in the
second slot ok so then none of these are
actually low level in coatings of zero
but they multiply 20 at the top level ok
okay so so given these sets of encodings
here's how the attack works so i indeed
i'm going to take one element 1 encoding
from each of the three sets and multiply
it so let's say i take the first one
from a and the first one from be yeah so
I you probably notice that I'm denoting
the be slightly different which will
make sense in a moment but let's say I
take the first encoding from a a 1 the
first encoding from B and from the be
set and the first encoding from the cisa
which is c 1 and i multiply these okay
so I haven't done anything here except
except notation so these are now encoded
at level 3 because they were each
encoded at level 1 and the CRT slots are
just the products of the slots from each
of the encoding but here again I'm
emphasizing that this is divisible by by
by G because it's an encoding of 0 ok
and again recall what the 0 test
parameter looks like it has the Z which
is going to cancel with here and then
when we multiply these two again these
geez are going to cancel here ok so
let's say I do that I take my three
encoding that i multiplied I'm x the
zero test parameter and I get something
oops I get something that looks like
this so again it's the CRT
representation of these products but
because of these like p I stars I can
just add I don't that's that's what the
CRT representation looks like ok and now
just to sort of clean up the notation a
bit I'm going to forget about what form
these actually have and just call these
system parameters so these Sigma's are
some parameters that depend on the
system and not on any of the encoding
and then the the CRT components of each
of the N coatings are multiplied so this
is the product of all of the first CRT
components and this is the product of
all the second CRT components for these
and coatings that i multiplied
okay so it has this form i'm going to
call this w 11 which means that i took a
1 and C 1 okay and I can oh sorry and
again this is crucial that this holds
over the integer so once i compute w11
in this way w 1 1 is equal to the sum
over the integers so no modular
reduction is needed in that equation
okay and this is this is crucial for
this attack these are small yes
everything that that's why this holds
over the integers because everything
here is small exactly even even these
system parameters are small relative to
X 0 okay so i can write this some in n
matrix vector form right because it's
just a it's just a bilinear form in some
sense right so i have this vector of the
Dai CRT of the a1c are two components
over here i have the c1 CRT components
okay and then in the middle i have this
this diagonal matrix which in the on the
i'th diagonal has the i'th CRT component
from b times whatever system parameter
is there for that slot okay so I'm very
close to the punch line for this this
attack right now I'm just just setting
up these matrices okay so I did this for
4 a 1 and C 1 and i called this w 11 but
I can do this for any way of choosing
something from the a and something from
the sea so in particular I can make a
matrix W right where the ice this the IJ
entry of W is AI times B times CJ okay
and it has this form so now let me just
let me take this in and move this up ok
so again i have this matrix W where the
IJ entry is the zero tested version of
the I think coding from a this middle
encoding be and the J thin coating from
see
okay and that matrix W has this
decomposition by the the properties of
the zero test okay let me clean this up
a little bit let me just call the the
stuff on the left and a matrix it's only
depended on the day and coatings and the
stuff on the right the C matrix only
depended on the sea in coatings okay so
we did this notice that we did this with
this be in the middle so this B was
fixed in every product okay I varied the
A's in the Seas but I kept to be the
same okay now i can do the same thing
but using the other middle encoding so
remember the the be set had these two
encodings b and b prime so i'm going to
construct exactly the same matrix but
using be prime instead of be okay so now
we have these two matrices that have
somewhat similar decompositions and we
would like to get some of these things
to start cancelling so that we can
recover you know the sort of internal
hidden values here okay so how do we get
these things to cancel well instead of
computing this w prime like this I'm
going to compute its inverse actually
which I can do over the integers rescued
me over the rationals okay so i won't go
into the details but with with high
probability each of these w matrices are
invertible and so if I invert the second
one of these you know this has the
effect of when you an excuse me when you
when you invert this matrix product you
just flip the order and invert each of
the things so now you get c minus one
over here yeah so you what you need is
that yeah you need these to be
invertible but these will be with high
probability over the randomness of the
encoding you can essentially think about
these as somewhat random numbers
yeah the encoding definitely need to be
independent the randomness needs to be
independent you need well it depends on
how many primes you're working with but
yes you need if you have n primes you
need n/a in coatings and NZ encodings
yeah so 0 maybe for these applications
you just need to be won 42-0 is that
that takes to the work that's a good
question which I'm not sure of the
answer type for that for the key
exchange I don't know if you need an
encoding 20 you do yeah okay
okay so so here's where we were we we
have these two matrices w w prime W
prime is inverted ok and now notice what
will happen if i multiply WN w prime
okay what'll happen is that these seas
will cancel and here these system
parameters Sigma will cancel okay so
when I multiply these two things again
over over the rationals what I'm left
with is this decomposition that has a on
one side and a may in verse on the other
and in the middle we have the ratios of
the CRT components of the B encodings
right so so b1 was the first CRT
component of B & B 1 prime is the first
year two component of B Prime okay so i
want to emphasize here that we the
attacker don't actually know these
values we only we compute a W and W
prime but we know that it has this
decomposition okay and now let's say we
want to recover the values here well we
can do that just with an eigenvalue
computation right so this matrix here
these it's a diagonal matrix so these
are the eigenvalues and the matrix that
we have is similar to this matrix
because it's in some sense conjugated by
a and so we the eigenvalues of this are
the same as the eigenvalues of this so
we can recover these internal values by
the eigenvalues look you this is over q
Who am not sure what your computing the
eigenvalues over kiss x 0 and you switch
to you right up i switch to q i switched
a cute when I took the inverse this is
the inverse of it
we go sure I mean I have a head I mean
unless you're going to stop you I mean I
have to have the matrix it's an integer
matrix and it's invertible yeah so I can
I can do this the reason why this all
works out is because is because yeah
it's because things are small because
these actually held over the integers
and not just mod X 0 that's what that's
why it's legal if these were big then
this would not work that's why
successful zero tests are kind of
crucial for this attack okay so so again
we can recover these ratios of the of
the CRT components using the bike by
computing the eigen values of this
matrix and with these you can actually
factor X 0 and break everything so so so
these are enough to sort of factor the
modulus recover the primes and you can
break everything good so I I was gonna
not do that but I can i can tell you
quickly the idea is that if i take be
so I take the encoding be okay and i'm
going to multiply by b prime 1 by the
the first CRT component and i'm going to
subtract B prime times v1 okay so notice
I sort of switch these this is the these
B&B primer the actual the actual CRT
encoding and and then these are the sort
of just components that I recovered no
no this is these are the Senators all of
these things are energized yeah so the
point is that so from that ratio you
you're saying you'll actually be covered
bi and bi prize so you you don't recover
them you recover their ratio so they may
they may have some factors in common but
even if they have factors in common the
following thing holds which is that you
can so you can compute something like
this these you know these be one prime
and and be one may be may be reduced by
their common factor but the point is
that this is divisible by P 1 okay and
the reason is that in in the first slot
the yeah it will get the value will get
zero doubt and it's just a visible by p1
okay and so the the point then is the
the GCD of the GCD of this and X 0 will
be equal to p1 this is this is how you
this is how you recover the print so I
want to talk about generalizations of
this attack i'm not sure how much time
is left because i want to leave maybe
sometimes 20 minutes okay so actually
maybe maybe i should just skip ahead and
let media if it's if it's all right ok
ok so i'll just say there are some
generalizations of this attack i already
mentioned when there's a
when you don't have low level zeros when
you just have things that multiply to
zero at the top level things still work
out there's another generalization where
even if you you don't directly get a
zero by multiplying but you need to sort
of compute some linear equation to get
the zeros again this still works out the
matrices just have higher dimension and
this breaks the the immunization of CLT
13 proposed by bone a woman Zimmerman
and then even if you have more general
relations among see encoding so not just
this sort of simple linear relation but
sort of more general linear relations
that you need to get zeros you can do
something very clever with the with the
Cayley Hamilton theorem which again is
probably more more details than I have
time to go into right now i'll just
quickly say so some consequences of
these are that these these attacks break
simplified variants of of some of the
sort of some obfuscation schemes so in
particular the the GAR get all branching
program obfuscation scheme and the
circuit obfuscation schemes proposed by
Zimmerman and Applebaum Bukowski so
these are not broken but simplified
variants of them very simplified
variants of them sort of trivial
trivially simplified variants of them
can be broken with these attacks okay
but again no candidate and see one
obvious Gator is known to be broken by
these attacks okay so let me let me let
me take over yeah zero out right so so
those in coatings do have the form to do
this attack so that assumption is broken
over CLT 13 because those zeros are in a
way such that you can multiply to get
top level 0 yeah
ok so now that's it ok so now I want to
describe how we sort of try to avoid
before the attack that Eric just
described so so abstracting things a bit
so so the reason why the attack works is
that you have so in some sense your
testing is linear or bad you can
construct widen our forms of integers
also have slightly different notations
I'm sorry so so this this thing here is
is the result of applying zero testing
to some to some encoding so of zero at
the top level so so this is a what Eric
denoted by your pzt time a mod X 0
something and so you had some like this
where so if if I do not buy see the
encoding question it's you have see
appearing here together with the things
with which you can use to construct the
matrices that Eric dicks will describe
so again so you wrote it in terms in
matrix term and and you do it twice you
divide and you can extract information
as I ghen values so so how can you avoid
this so as I said an approach that
didn't seem to work out is trying to
keep the exact same number theoretic
construction but somehow use a more
complex representation of the encoding
so that it doesn't seem so easy to
combine the encoding in such a way that
they
produce the zeros that you need at the
top level two to obtain the relations
that let you break let the attack work
out so so for example you had this he
mentioned the Bonnie Blue Zimmerman
can't counter measure where in some
sense so in codings where represented as
pairs of CLT 13 encodings and sort
somehow and so you could make sure that
they you didn't get low level encodings
of zeros but still you can combine them
so that you can get encoding of zero at
the top level and indeed so since 0
testing was basically the same it still
had this linear structure and you still
could express the zero tested value as a
bit by linear form and the attack out
lies exactly the same just with a larger
dimensional matrices so in the last part
of the talk Eric will say things that
hopefully can be done in that spirit but
we here in 30 15 we'd take a different
approach so the idea is that in codings
themselves in principle there shouldn't
be a problem like so essentially so in
coatings in CLT orangish there if like
fhe cipher texts for the kind of fhe
scheme that they are inspired from so in
our case they look very much like cipher
text for fhe over the integers so if you
don't give out the pzt the zero testing
parameter then
they pretty much episode the random I
say almost because the shape is slightly
different but so you don't exactly get
security proof but almost so so the
problem is zero testing so the fact that
zero testing is you can get those
bilinear form 0 testing so we that we
want to break so what we try to do is
keep the basic structure of CNT 13 but
just multiply not modify the 0 testing
procedure to make it nonlinear in some
sense so the way we do this is a
carry-out 0 testing with the different
modulus then we do modulus we use for
Malkina operators so we introduce so in
coatings of steel CRT values not some X
0 but for 220 testing we check whether p
ZT x see where a pzt is a suitable value
is a small modulo some independently
chosen prime which is larger than X 0 so
I'll describe this in more details in
this file so so just to what to describe
what CLT does another child so we keep
the same CLT encodings so but we modify
the 0 testing in such way that we we
think the 0 tested value can't be
expressed as a bilinear form anymore so
the new arithmetic technique is to map
the CRT components of the of a given
encoding to some value Maduro an
independent integer in such a way that
you can do 00 testing by testing whether
things are large or small with respect
to n okay so and in so the attack by
janitor doesn't seem to generalize that
setting so you can't write
you can't construct such a matrix WC
anymore you you still have a matrix
representation but it has additional
terms which are nonlinear and so when
you try to divide two such matrices that
you don't get anything interesting a
party ok so again so CLT encoding is
over Z they look like this so that's
exactly the same thing as a liquor rod
it's a slightly different notation so so
C is the encoding and if you reduce it
much p I then it looks like the value am
I plus some randomness that depends on
that's x that's divisible by GI divided
by Y or Z to the Kappa at level kappa ok
so another way to write this is like
this so I just expand everything with
CRT so the CRT components are obtained
with relation of that form so you invert
the rest of the modulus mod the pie and
you multiply by a component modulo P I
etc so you have a over Z so once I'm I
reduce everything mod X 0 i can write
this relation over Z and I get a term
next return here which correspond to
integer division allegiant division by
x0 so here is rest values the sea is the
components of rpi times some constant
minus a times X 0
okay so that's the structure and I said
that I can could do zero testing modulo
an independently picked random large
prime and provided that i can find an
element pz t mod n such that when i pick
all of those terms and i multiply them
by x pz t they become small compared to
n so why is that because so if i can
find such a pzt then i take this
relation i multiply everything by pzt
and the UI become VI in the X 0 time
multiplied by P that it becomes V zero
and so this thing so suppose all da mice
are are 0 then all i get is our I times
V I RI is very small and VI small
compared to N and I am eight times V 0
and if all the m IL 0 then the size of a
is the same as the size of the our eyes
which is a important remark and so it's
all so small so everything is small if
all Emma's are 0 whereas if if not all
Emma's are 0 then this thing will get
larger as the size of P and a will get
larger as well and this won't be small
anymore so that's the idea so how can I
find such an element pzt which to remind
you is such that so you eyes are
parameters that depends on the pis and
so such taps p ZT x UI modern is small
for all you is and v-0 is also small so
in some sense that lattice problem
so I want to to find a small it's it's
the same as finding a short vector in a
lattice of dimension n plus 1 something
like this the lattice generated by the
UI's and x0 and with a diagonal of ends
something so so in principle till we I
don't need a very small approximation
factor so I could do this with lln but
doing LLL so in practice and is
something like 10,000 so Ln the lattice
of dimension 10,000 it's not sure it's a
good idea so we exploit the fact that
the UI's have a special form that makes
our job easier so the special form is
like this something like that they all
depend on each other they're closely
they are basically multiples of a CRT
components so in our case so n is a bit
larger than x0 something like X so X is
the size of x0 times the size of one of
the pies and then what we claim is that
if you take you I like this and you
divide it by some one of the primes over
then p I so if you divide it by you one
of the prime over then p I then it
becomes small boat and because it
becomes small or large integers because
PJ for I are different from j divides X
0 and so it divides you I and so you can
divide it by 8 mod n so this is small so
your only problem is a when the two
indices I quad and it makes your job
much simpler so the minus K that's a
huge number so why is it small yeah but
all this thing is just modular plaxo so
it's just the size of x0
so the only thing you need to deal with
is the those terms you want to make them
small so that's that's doable just with
ll n dimension to this time so you can
find by balancing the components
something which is oxidized hoods of
hood of P something like this such that
this thing is of size at most n / would
be something so and so both of those
things become small and so then all of
those terms all of those products will
be small mod n so some because they are
already small and you multiply by
something small and the others because
it's just bitter J and so you take a
condom linear combination with spawn
parameters of those things and you get
your zero testing element which
satisfies the property that we wanted
okay so i won't i will need more than
two minutes hoping you can you give me
five hour
into our discussion time five minutes
thank you very much okay so so so one
important thing to note is that the x0
that we consider the since the beginning
must be kept private in this scheme the
reason is that if you make it public
then I can do the the trial nettle
attack modulo v-0 here so so every
describe the Chalmette all attack / the
/ z / or / q but you could carry it out
in a different / different field and
sofa or a ring and in this case the ring
of integers mod v-0 is a perfectly fine
ring to carry out the same attack so you
can do it and it would break things and
it would break everything because the 0
testing parameter has exactly the same
form not V 0 as it did in this previous
situation so you must keep x0 public and
that's that's rather inconvenient
because when you add and multiply
encoding then you can't reduce things
mod X 0 anymore which is inconvenient
and it's even more important 40 testing
at the end because remember that zero
testing use the fact that your encoding
was small enough such that the a term at
the end this this a-here was of the same
size as the arise for example so you
need to even though you you don't have
x0 need to a way to reduce the size of
encodings at each step so you can do
this by publishing a ladder of random
encodings of zeros and reducing bit by
bit so that's the technique that that's
been known forever so in produce input
impractical it was in it was used in for
the original fhe scheme of the integers
by your van dyk Italian 2010 which is
forever going this video's terms okay so
so then the question is that so have we
really stopped the attack this this
relation for the description of the zero
testing is not such so different than
CLT 30 but you have this critical term a
times V zero which doesn't depend
linearly on the our eyes and so it seems
that whatever you do you will still have
this term where a obscures everything
and avoids this division trick that the
chanel whereby able to carry out
moreover so as i explained just in a
minute ago so a minute ago you can't do
zero testing directly on the product of
lower level encodings you must first
reduce the the your product to something
which is of the size of x0 before you
can x pz g and this means that you have
to carry out the size reduction step by
adding letters of encoding somehow in
those leather terms also add some
non-linearity that seemed to thwart the
attack as well so in the end you will
have a zero test a real zero testing
term of this form where you have two
types of additional terms the essays
which come from the ladder and the a
which comes from the Allegiant division
of those things by x0 and all of those
are nonlinear in in the components of
the CIO and so those additional terms
seem to make the attack
not work so that that's of course
another precise statement maybe you
could somehow modify the attack to make
it work but we haven't found a way to do
this I want to talk about setting
parameters but let's restate that
there's a implementation of this bio tom
hutler one who is here so you can play
with it if you want and the actual
parameters not especially worse than the
pre do one on in CLT 13 which is not a
very strong statement ok that's it from
one word okay yeah so okay I mean yeah
so this is the idea of posterizing
obfuscation is not to allow any 0
encodings at all so never allow anyone
to create a 0 encoding and none of these
attacks work so that's it we're done ok
but you know you need 0 and coatings
because sometimes function output
functions output 0 so think of it just
in the case of evasive functions so
where it's hard to find a zero out but
then then this makes sense and these
attacks at least are not obviously
applicable yeah you can do that to
function yes obfuscates evasive
functions and shows that an adversary
which which sort of follows the rules
never creates a zero encoding so you
know in all of these yer izing attacks
the adversary follows the rules right it
adds and multiplies though in the way
it's supposed to ok so and you know you
might think that this follows from the
fact that we're talking about evasive
functions but you know getting a
function output of zero is not the only
way to go to zero so you know this does
require some some work to prove that
in addition to not being able to get
zero outputs you can't get any zeros at
all collision can't you subtract the
outlets yeah but the so if you get a
collision of ones all right what that
means is that they're equal as boolean
functions but the underlying field
element is not the same it's it's
something you know random ish that's not
zero so even if you have two outputs
that are both won the the actual field
element that's encoded in each case is
not the same so when you subtract it
will not be an encoding is here that's
that's a good point though ok yeah and
and so there's a sort of like key
theorem which which allows to prove this
which sort of shows that the types of
encodings you can create and some of
these obfuscation schemes is very
restricted and I think it's it's
conceivable that you know you could use
this theorem to prove something like
that with these office cajon schemes you
just can't get the types of encodings
you need for these zeros in tax what we
have is is just to prove that you can't
get zeros with evasive functions but you
know conceivably this this theorem could
be used to prove more than that ok I'll
leave include enough
you